the boys after getting hände der horst
[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine damen und herren zu einem neuen
video auf meinem youtube kanals bereits
im titel eingeblendet und zwar reagieren
wir heute gemeinsam aufnehmen
zum dritten weltkrieg deswegen habe ich
ja auch schon meine muskeln ausgepackt
erstmal falls sie hinterm mond leben
sollte eine kurze erklärung die usa
haben vor einigen tagen mit einem
gezielten drohnenangriffe einen
ranghohen general des iranischen
militärs getötet namens so lehmann
näheres ist vergleichbar mit den usa so
als würde der amerikanische
vizepräsident umgebracht werden also nur
damit ihr wisst was der sulimani für
eine macht stufe in dem iran hatte und
klar der ganze usa iran konflikt der
existiert schon seit jahren und der
krieg wird auch seit jahren geführt
allerdings hat es dadurch jetzt nochmal
eine komplett neue eskalationsstufe
erreicht
ich will mit meinem video allerdings
überhaupt nicht irgendwie hier ein
politisches statement abgeben und sagen
ja das war richtig aber der falsche
zeitpunkt und es war komplett falsch und
die die stabilität den kompletten
mittleren osten und keine ahnung was ich
bin kein nachrichtensender keine
politische news agentur ich habe euch
dazu super artikel unter die
beschreibung passt euch darüber
informieren möchte denn wir reagiert
meint ihr passt runter gefallen das
bespreche hitze eigentlich ganz gut dass
jetzt das nächste mine und zwar fordert
kids wonderland in ihrer
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob scheiße ist darüber zu
machen es ist ein so ernstes thema und
das muss auch so gehandhabt werden
allerdings gibt es halt so viele leute
die sich gerade darüber lustig machen
und nimmt darüber machen und ich finde
es ein bisschen comedy jetzt in diesem
wirklich bisher beschlossenen jahr 2020
gut eigentlich ganz gut und dann machen
wir direkt weiter mit diesem minus war
mir gut hier und dann seht ihr schon
dass die das halt so hofft dass 2020
gutes jahr und sich nicht einfach nur
ein gekürzt und auf dem sofa
ja
so habe ich mich auch gefühl tausend
apps wie looking at the track
[Musik]
es ist halt alles so witzig aber auf der
anderen seite kündigt so passieren da
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich aber wie
bereits gesagt wir wollen nicht über die
ganzen hintergrunde quatschen blabla
sondern wir schauen uns - aber meine
lieben freunde und das jetzt das nächste
der army look in people see ots letztes
youtube testing friendly fire ist ein
after biegen die pleite in detroit
abbiegen platz ganz kurze erklärungen zu
dem wort treffe weil das er jetzt schon
das zweite oder dritte mal vorgekommen
ist
die usa haben damals in den vorherigen
kriegen leute irgendwie eingezogen zum
militär bloody ich weiß nicht genau was
die voraussetzung sind aber irgendwie
zwischen 18 und 25 und körperlich und
physisch fit seien viele leute einmal
halt gerade angst in amerika dass sie
eingezogen und dann zum iran geschickt
werden viele leute machen auch ein
größeres fass auf wirklich wie sharing
the world was ich weiss nicht
rechtfertige mich hier gerade nach jedem
minen und zum tausendsten mal jetzt
schon und ich werde wahrscheinlich auch
überhaupt kein held gegeben unter dem
video habe ich möchte einfach direkt
sagen ich möchte hier wirklich
keineswegs das thema herunter reden das
ist ein thema wo trump wirklich wieder
rein innenpolitisch gedacht hat und
überhaupt nicht außenpolitische
konsequenzen irgendwie zu seinem
gedanken strengen da zugezogen hat aber
mehr kann können wir grafiken und ich
wäre ja ein paar mails zeigen dass wir
ein bisschen zusammen lachen me love in
the world
[Musik]
hundertprozentig wenn ihr job
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bevor ich ganz gut zur info ich reagiere
auf die wachen während ich durch
twitters krone und alles worüber ich
lachen muss und vorlese das lade ich mir
darunter sie weder selbst alle zum
ersten mal world rimini hübsches ist hat
nicht der von die office world we begin
call of duty 3 6 - das sind hier viele -
die tage auf tik tok unterwegs und habe
auch dort schon extrem viele world of
games gesehen aber halt videos und soll
ich darauf machen gehen ich wollte jetzt
gehe eigentlich immer dienstags also
morgen wollte die tik tok eustace machen
neue serie wo ich euch lustige tik tok
stadtrat et also grad immer gern und in
die kommentare ob ich dann morgen auf
world wars rimini videos und tik tok
reagieren soll
they can't get you if they can ziehen
[Musik]
er wird wahrscheinlich extra in den
krieg eingezogen war das so schlau ist
und mir immer bei swatch ingeborg holz
und aua college in world of targeting
hände
[Musik]
was ist denn los mit einigen leute das
kann doch nicht wahr sein aber gut ok
schauen wir mal weiter
tobias levels die witzigsten reaction
aufgenommen habe aber auf der anderen
seite fühle ich mich als scheiße weil es
halt ein ernster hintergrund ist und
klar ich meine bei - ist es oft so dass
es halt um den ernsten hintergrund jedem
leute machen sich irgendwie halt die kuh
ironisch darüber lustig und keine ahnung
was aber bitte nehmt mir das einfach
nicht übel aber gut wir machen weiter
mit diesen die leute so viele spongebob
vergleiche einfach schon die for
worldwide american t shirt an after what
remains viva mexico ja ich würde auch
die rektoren wollen da wie wondering how
des landes reisinger
[Musik]
ich fühle mich ich wollte mich anlehnen
auf dem tisch kann ich davon ganz kurze
nochmals locken will destroy piece for
life soft 1000 we can you cod gamer
[Musik]
da geht es wieder um diese trifft
geschichte
ich weiß nicht ob irgendwelche das habe
ich aber letztens gesehen ich bekomme
echte einige bewährt ich habe letztes
nachricht bekommen von einem mädchen aus
amerika die meint dass die versucht
deutsch zu lernen mit hilfe meiner
videos erstmal habe ich diesen
kompletten satz grammatikalisch richtig
hingekriegt gerade allerdings falls
irgend jemand von euch in amerika wohnt
kriegt ihr richtig krass schon was davon
mit und dieser ganzen geschichte weil
leute meinen schon dass einige irgendwie
briefe bekommen kleine kamera wie
gamespot ja wahrscheinlich erklärte
horne countries and wealth of the waves
cruz london uk der capital dance when
you can ja
amerika wie man sie kennt schätzt und
fürchtet france info uk frankreich
frankreich wo in call of duty players
are the world we and realize it with
skills read only get you
posttraumatische belastungsstörung heißt
es glaube ich ein oder tactical nuke
something wrong
ja ich glaub ich viele leute denken dass
der krieg zu absolvieren so videospielen
krieg wird mittlerweile echt anders
geführt und klickte ich mich regt auf
dass er leute sagen ja usa iran ihre
pflichten krieg aus der krieg existiert
schon längst so also wie bereits gesagt
so ich bin nicht in der position ich
habe jetzt auch nicht das krasse wissen
will ganze thematik näher zu bringen ich
verlinke euch einige gute videos und
nachrichten artikel unten bitte schauten
die video beschreibung lest euch das
durch weil das ist ein riesiges thema
gerade es ist wichtig dass man darüber
informiert
[Musik]
ich sterbe nur bei diesem video oder
dann halt im dritten weltkrieg james
charles wood hat me the government s
knocking on my dort trefft
alles klar james logan vorne iran after
realizing the wall will create etwas
ändert ist böse
der ist extrem böse world's worst
restart people rating als 50 reisende
military made easy fold leute das ist
jetzt unsere chance die wahrheit zu
nehmen und kommt machen wir noch ein
letztes team für heute freunde vielen
maske after realizing vertikale volk
über das wie bei fleisch ja freunde an
der stelle mich dass solche wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden wie bereits
gesagt ich möchte keine politische
äußerungen abgeben oder irgendwas sagen
dass alleine so stehen will gar nix
sagen ich wollte mit meinem heutigen
video hier lediglich einige - anschauen
live zusammen mit euch die ich gerade
gefunden habe und wenn es euch gefallen
da würde ich mich sehr darüber einen
daumen hoch freuen wie bereits gesagt
schaut gerne in die infobox dort findet
ihr nachrichten artikel zu dem ganzen
thema falls es überhaupt nicht
mitbekommen haben solltet das halt alles
voll damit aber es gibt immer noch leute
wieder was ich habe vier tage geschissen
aber nicht mal ein kanal falls noch
keinen teer der luxus sein weil bald ist
gibt uns allen nicht mehr und schreibt
mir gerne und in den kommentare ob ich
morgen auch auf einige tik tok in videos
zum world water oder allgemeinen auf der
lustige videos mal wieder
[Musik]